a bit less we babies are having a crisis
to chew her God face the day I see the
boss baby the boss baby my god I've been
reviewing movies on YouTube since 2009
and I wrote reviews and movies before
that I'm rarely embarrassed to say that
I saw a film but in the case of the boss
baby and Smurfs the lost village my very
nice wife said hey you know I'll go see
it with you if you go we'll sit through
it together and I was like okay so now I
get to review the boss baby this movie
is about a baby that's an adult and it's
in a baby's body basically it's like a
baby that was made I guess by some
factory and it has the intellect of an
adult voiced by Alec Baldwin who gets
sent to a family with a mother that was
pregnant but the baby arrives in a
taxicab and the older brother is really
jealous and he's not getting time with
his parents as much anymore so he wants
to do something about this baby before
it's too late too before he loses his
family forever so they have to kind of
become a small team to figure out how to
get exactly what the other person wants
and I don't really understand this movie
actually it's a little confusing this is
a film that is in a way told from the
perspective of the main boy the older
boy you get a narration from Tobey
Maguire and you assume that that is him
as an older person now telling a story
to somebody or something and so we get
to watch this young
kid get used to having a baby brother
but he also has a very active
imagination and we're often shown these
sequences where he is using his
imagination the animation format changes
and it's very old-school style very
1960s 1970s retro animation in which
he's a pirate or he's in a space he's
doing fun things with his parents but as
the film continues and more and more
magical impossible things start
happening the line between his
imagination and reality kind of got
blurred for me as the viewer and I was
like okay did that just actually happen
because that makes no sense and
something happens at the very end of
this movie that I won't spoil of course
but it kind of makes you sit back and go
okay so does that make sense now all of
a sudden but then something else happens
and you're like oh okay so now I guess
it is weird and what the hell just
happened this is for kids right the
filmmaker chooses to specifically
animate the imagination sequences
completely differently from the things
that are actually happening and so
whenever he is like pretending to be a
pirate or he's on the high seas you're
like okay I get it he's using his
imagination right now to give himself
courage to do something that maybe he
was afraid of or just to have fun but
then later in the movie where there's a
rocket ship and magical puppies and
airport security that's the worst
airport security I've ever seen in my
life
these seem to be animated as if they're
actually happening and so I don't really
understand what the filmmakers trying to
say with this movie let's forget about
all that because honestly no kids to
this movie is going to care is this
movie funny will kids be entertained by
it I would say Alec Baldwin is really
good as the baby the actor who portrays
the young boy is also really good there
is a nice little bond that develops
between the two and what this movie
really touches on that I think kids can
take away from in a positive way is the
fear that you get as a child when you
discover you might be having a sibling
and you wonder is the attention going to
win for me or my parents still going to
love me this is something that I think
kids will appreciate and possibly take
away from the movie the eventual message
that we learn and since it does touch on
that fear that a lot of kids have when
they find out they're going to get a
brother or a sister that is probably the
most praiseworthy aspect of this film
along with the really good animation
strangely I'm not entirely sure where
this movie takes place either
it seems to have in 1970s aesthetic
pretty much every song is from around
that era there's a lot of Elvis stuff as
well in this movie and pretty much all
of the fonts for the opening titles or
when they go to a city and you see the
welcome to this city sign the font is
very retro and it almost seems like it's
taking place in the 60s or 70s it is
weird that I'm thinking that much about
the boss baby why am I thinking that
much about the boss baby don't don't
have anything else better to do today
besides sit here and analyze the boss
baby the first half the movie was just
kind of annoying the baby was just way
too much he really got on my nerves and
towards the second half it did pick up a
little bit as the two begin to bond but
the film just doesn't really make sense
it's almost like it takes place in a
fantasy world and as I said when the
film ends you're given a little thing
where you're like oh okay well maybe now
it does kind of make sense but then
something else happens that kind of
ruins all that so this movies kind of an
enigma again I'm looking at this from an
adult perspective kids who see this
movie will be like baby made funny jokes
yeah they talked about poop and the kid
got hit in the balls yay
poop and balls I don't know I'm going to
give the boss baby a seed it's not awful
it looks a lot worse than it is the
trailers for this movie make it seem
like it's a complete pile of there
are some good messages for kids and the
animation is pretty good and there are a
few adult jokes that my wife and I
laughed at but in the end it's pretty
much an annoying forgettable movie that
doesn't really make sense when you think
about it guys thank you so much as
always for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
menage
[Music]
you